by the end of this video you're going to
be able to replicate this exact modern
farmhouse in archicad 25
even if you've never used the program
before what's going on guys my name is
david thomich i'm a registered architect
here in western australia and on this
channel we talk all things architecture
and technology without further ado let's
turn around and get started with today's
tutorial so today we're going to be
starting with this modern farmhouse
design and we're going to be replicating
it in archicad 25. it is relatively
simple it is relatively straightforward
to create it is basically two boxes
intersecting together with a pitched
roof and some unique claddings so what
we're going to be focusing on is a
little bit of the architectural
detailing and the style more than
anything i'm going to go through a lot
more of this cladding system in detail
in my next video so if you want to check
that out it'll be coming out next week
make sure you subscribe for that one
let's start by using our slab tool and
our rectangular slab section and next
we're going to draw a 20 meter box by
let's say 7 meters wide gives us a
relatively nice shape next we're going
to click on that general slab click on
one of the nodes hit the plus button and
then somewhere along this rear right
hand side
we're just going to simply draw another
extension of that property so let's make
this 5 meters wide and 7 meters long so
that's looking a little bit too long for
me personally so i'm going to select the
outer line click on it once go up to the
top and basically offset my edge and i'm
going to type in 2 000 for two meters
now as you can see we've got the
starting point of our actual shape
coming into marquee selecting the whole
marquee making sure that you have the
thick dash line selected so you can see
everything right click show marquee in
3d you're going to see that we've
created a very generic slab for a
starting point coming back to our ground
floor plan let's click on our wall tool
let's select walls external any wall
type that you want because we are going
a cluttered system i'm going to go for a
stud partition wall
and simply draw the outside perimeter of
this house when you finish drawing the
house you can come back into 3d you can
see that our walls have quickly been
erected and they're basically ready to
go that's one of the best things about
arc cad you don't have to draw over and
over again
coming back to our ground floor plan
we're going to press command up to go to
our roof or our ceiling right click on
the floor below that we were just using
and go show as trace reference so now we
see the floor below us and we can start
creating our roof
if we come across to our roof tool
select the multi-pane roof tool and
simply follow the outside of the roof
itself once you finish that off you're
going to see a very generic roof
structure which isn't at all what we
want so what we're going to do is right
click on that roof and go split into
single pane rows it's going to come up
with a little bit of a warning we're
going to split anyway next we're going
to click alt g or option g depending on
your system and we're going to delete
these three sections here by simply
clicking on them and deleting next we're
going to select two of these roof panes
select one of the hot nodes and click on
our adjustment tool hold shift so it
aligns and make our first gable now i'm
going to repeat that with the other two
remaining sides as well and there we go
now we have our three gable roofs coming
into our 3d we're going to see that
we've created that very simple roof
structure what i can tell straight away
is that roof structure is way too low so
i'm going to increase the overall pitch
to about 30 degrees maybe even 35
degrees to simply make this a very high
pitched roof now coming back to our
inspirational photo here we can see that
the roof has no eaves no overhang
whatsoever so we'll come back to our
roof floor plan we're going to show this
as our trace reference again
if you can't see anything underneath
we're going to come across
up top to our trace reference section
and make sure it is see-through by
selecting that last little
icon on the right-hand side next what
we're going to do is simply select one
of the edges and offset them all the way
back in line with our walls
so it's as simple as that i'm going to
repeat the process for the rest of this
house and there we have it i've offset
all those roof lines in line with the
outside of the walls so now if i come
back into 3d we'll see that we have no
more overhangs and no more eaves
the next thing we want to do is select
one of these gable end walls
select one of the hot link nodes and
extend it past the top of our roof
i'm going to repeat the same for the
other two and then i'm going to select
my three walls right click connect and
then solid element operations by
selecting solid element operations after
we've selected those walls it
automatically selects them as a target
next we can
select all of our roof structure go add
as operator subtract with upwards
extrusion and execute there we go
simple as that we cut off all of our
walls very very rapidly and leave
nothing but the general shape that we're
working with if you're an architect
student or anybody in the architecture
industry make sure you check out
davidtomage.com.edu for all of your
digital architectural requirements one
of the best things on the site is the
construction checklist it will basically
give you a fundamental starting point of
everything that needs to be on a set of
architectural documents before it goes
out for construction it doesn't matter
if you're a student or even if you're a
seasoned professional this checklist is
going to make sure your work is better
every single day now what we're left
with is the basic shell and the basic
structure that we're trying to replicate
in this image here on the left hand side
which is becoming very very simple very
very quick for us so next we're going to
introduce a few sliding windows a few
sliding doors and replicate that shape
around the outside so if we come back
into our ground floor plan go to our
window tool on the left hand side open
up the window settings either here or by
pressing command t typing in window as
an example and then then selecting one
of the windows available to you in
archicad
so for instance i'm simply going to
select that window at the very top i'm
going to make it about 3 meters wide and
1500 tall seems approximately right
and all i'm going to do then is
introduce this into the project
on this side here coming back into 3d to
see what we've created what we've done
is replicated a very similar window it
needs to be a little bit taller so i'm
going to extend the height of that
window up to the top and next i'm going
to open up those settings and change the
actual settings so it matches the black
monument style we have in this reference
image coming up to our settings going to
model attributes and simply changing our
frame style to monument we create a very
similar window as to what we see in our
reference image what i'm going to do now
is simply replicate a few more of those
windows by holding the alt button and
tapping it a couple more times across
this project what i can see is on the
gable end there is this beautiful large
picture frame window so the easiest way
for me to do that is simply come down to
window 25 change that to 3 meters wide
and 2 1 4 5 i believe was roughly the
size we can adjust that in a minute
change our materials back to black click
ok come back into 3d to make sure that
those windows are roughly the right size
it's definitely too wide too big and the
wrong style so what i'll do is adjust
the right height make sure the level is
matte and then i'm going to reduce the
width by about a meter because i think
it's too big last but not least i'm just
going to open up those settings and make
sure that it is a fixed window rather
than a side hung so fixed glass okay and
there we go we have our large picture
frame window looking at this image here
it looks like these windows are
significantly larger so i'm just going
to drag them out all the way to the
bottom
and i'm going to make one of these a
sliding door rather than a sliding
window now we have the fundamental
basics of this entire project what we
don't have is the cladding system and
the roof system which makes this project
stand out and looks so incredible so the
easiest and truly the easiest way to do
this is by using ci tools coverings
which i'm going to go into in a lot more
detail in the next project but simply
what we need to do is basically select
all of our roof go up to ci tools
coverings let's go roof covering and i'm
going to change my rooftop to ribbed and
i'm going to extend this profile so i'm
going to make a about 350 i'm going to
make b
9
c 50 d
18 and
e i'm going to leave as 40. i'm going to
make sure that is again black to match
our window frames click ok
and what you'll see is an amazing roof
structure automatically created by
archicad to go into even more detail if
we come back into our ground floor plan
we're going to see that roof structure
appear so for instance i'm going to
select just this one roof structure hit
that pink hot spot which is my down pipe
drag it a little bit across to create
the down pipe and then i'm going to
introduce my dow pipe in this exact
corner as they have it on the reference
image so coming back to 3d we're going
to see we've created our downpipe very
quickly we can extend that down pipe all
the way down to the ground hide it away
from use and sight and we've been able
to replicate that roof structure
incredibly quickly and incredibly easily
now to create this beautiful ash
cladding what we're going to do is
select all of our walls we're going to
come back into our ci tools go coverings
and this time we're going to go into our
wall coverings rather than our actual
roof coverings so what you can see see
our tools automatically has a number of
profiles set up which shiplaps smooth is
exactly what we're looking for in this
instance we're going to change this to a
light oak color so it gives us that
beautiful finish that we're looking for
and for the starting purpose of this
we're just simply going to press ok
then it's going to ask us do we want to
put it on the inside or the outside of
the wall obviously the outside clicking
once we're going to see that completed
wood structure
now obviously that cladding is way too
dark in comparison to what we're looking
at in the image so we could obviously go
in and click all of our wall cladding
open up the settings and find a better
surface override a nicer lighter color
now i don't have one personally on file
but it's very easy and very quick to
replicate something else for instance we
could even use something like a paint
white haven which would give us that
light oak ash color that we're looking
for
even though there's little to no wood
grain available on that surface now now
what you'll notice is the trim basically
has also come out in monuments so if we
open up those settings we can go through
all of these settings and change
individual trims piece by piece or we
can simply override that entire surface
go to whitehaven click ok and get that
nice timber trim that we see in our
reference image as well that's all from
me my name is david thomach i'll see you
next time